too
hey it's friend we're back we're back i
get to kill you today
why oh 10 ways to kill you should i just
throw that episode trying to find ways
to kill you like see that light fall on
your head strangle you with the
microphone cord this is the final
destination it's like we're just doing
adam's family i'm always thinking about
ways to die kill me i was on that show a
thousand ways to die on spike tv like
four times
you remember that show
and you get yourself my my i was talking
about breast implants and how they like
explode on the in on airplanes what does
that show it's just weird ways people
don't i think it's fake yeah
and so you're thinking you're always
thinking of ways to die
um i didn't oh me i always think i
always think like right now i could see
like that pole falling all over hitting
you know i had the lightning and the
computer slamming on everything like
this strangling you like choking on
water like or just magically start
straining yeah something goes in flames
like no i mean there's so many things
that could happen here i always think
about that so maybe today you're like a
special ops you're like a bodyguard
you're just assessing all the risks i do
i'm so paranoid today i almost got
attacked in our car here
today's episode is sponsored by upstart
and quip you got well you got swamp my
makeup artist also canceled on me today
so i had to go to cvs and get all this
makeup cause i literally don't own
makeup and i have skincare coming out
today but my skin is peeling because i
got a facial on saturday so if you guys
know anything about facials awkward
i like my skin but like it is better
it's just like this appealing today but
it is launching i thought you walked in
i thought your makeup looked good i
really do oh i feel so bad and then we
were at starbucks and literally not
joking most contestants i think the
school came out of session or something
there was literally like 20 kids
surrounding i was trying to take video
and they're like knocking on the window
i'm on facetime with my mom i'm like can
you not and then they're like taking a
picture i felt like i felt like an
animal i was not cool i was not having a
good day a day so hard being famous oh
no it's a you know i usually like it but
in your car that's so scary you don't
know what it's like to be like i'd
rather be in my car than outside with
the
vultures not me i'm like okay i'll say
hi but i'm on
people are more hyped to see you to be
honest um people get real excited when
they see you i usually get really
excited to see people but in my car i'm
just like i feel so and my skin was i
was just like and it's gloomy it's
raining today it's just like a one and
then i'm in a costume
i don't even know what this is like i
can't even like cosplay because i don't
know what it is you're the madam sound
you're debbie from adam sandler this was
your idea for madame sandler or adam's
family
this was your idea i'm not gonna fester
oh my god this is so you're right
i don't have ideas okay well hold on
just so people know
and debbie well hold on does anyone
remember because i don't have ideas
these are your ideas you got it off
reddit and you're like we're gonna do
this and i'm like i don't like i'm this
is definitely not my idea you told me
you didn't like it my idea would be maui
and moana my idea would be sharpay and
ryan from high school musical i have so
i've never once picked our costumes
never once what never once you go back
check another thing never once you have
never once picked up never once okay
show this i don't want to be the girl in
the movies i want to be the boy too like
i want to be able to be like okay well
this is us anyway this is uncle fester
and debbie she's like the black widow
serial killer they kill all of her
husbands
and you you're s you're crushing it so i
don't know why you i wasn't making all
this didn't even know this movie how
would i even come up with this this was
literally your idea we need to pause for
real because i will i will find it right
now you sent this and another one back
to back and i was like cause you find it
off reddit and you send it and i'm like
i don't know who these characters are
but you know what you're right
you're right i think it was a reddit
post people were like i know it was
because i've never seen this movie how
would i know okay well you look great
what's the problem because i just don't
feel cute i'm just like like what is
this character what am i supposed to do
with this all day why are you
complaining about it now he spent like
all this time planning it because he was
always like why are you kind of sitting
here now that we're doing it and
complain just own it i was trying to be
a people pleaser and then i was like
yeah yeah let's do it what about well
you're cutting short of being the people
pleaser you dropped the ball at the most
important part of pleasing the people
monday april 19th ethan goes i already
admitted it was me
why is everyone gaslighting me and
making me think i admit it was me i said
you were right i remembered it was a
reddit post
no lights no gas
okay i'm happy to be here but you
obviously i want to be the one that gets
to kill it in costume i want to be the
one that gets makeup and hair and all
this like i have to just be this random
like nobody knows who this person is
everybody knows debbie the black widow
yeah that's a real famous character i
can't you can't find one tick tock you
give me you give me one idea and we'll
do whatever you want to be maui and you
be moana no next i'm kidding we can do
that i was just kidding i want to be
sharpay and you be ryan from high school
musical and we can sing to the top
up up to the top can i be george
washington you be hamilton
i don't really like hamilton though i
would love i'd rather be sorry i
wouldn't i don't like ham oh you don't
want it
and you be hamilton but george
washington's cool nobody knows george
washington uh in the show sorry george
watch it first of all in the historical
context you're wrong and in the show
george washington's a main character so
whatever i don't really like him in the
show
i saw the original cast i didn't really
like him in the show but
all right let's move on anyways yeah he
dies of old age jesus it's not like a
big deal
it's not like a loser well they died of
young age back then they were dying he
made it he did it all did he die of old
age how old was he though how old was he
i don't know people died but like
probably in 70 years okay i'm down for a
hamilton cosplay for sure but no that's
my idea you give me the idea because
we'll show up there and
yeah i didn't like it that much
i think that's the fun part that's like
the fun movie of disney movie
i'm just having a rough go of it today
i'm telling you my period my skin
everything can i talk about my skincare
real quick and then we'll just get out
of the way
fishskin.com
love that domain
it's good i have a bunch of domains for
this but trishkin.com um you have more
domains like which other ones uh there's
patis miracle elixir trish
there yeah they're kind of long
patrician i like miracle elixir though
well miracle elixir is the name of my
product it's like a traveling
sweeney todd so i did a music video for
this that's coming out friday is it what
do you what do you think i referenced it
earlier and you were like what are you
talking about what's when the sweet i
said uh what's his name per peroni rally
correlation wait when did you say that
just a few minutes okay come on plug
yourself
that's crazy that you knew that yeah so
this is what you get the packaging is
amazing this is all manufactured
produced and formulated here in la um
it's made fresh so once you order it
it's like made the things are ready to
go but yeah nice package we got foam
yeah we got the cleanser we got day
cream night cream you guys this actually
like works so obviously for the record i
feel like people
i feel like i don't need to say this but
a lot of people are like confused
they're like why would we buy skincare
from trish it's obviously i'm in
collaboration like the face with um glow
skin enhancement that's the people who
made it well you found you were using a
hair care or a face care system and it
really worked yeah i saw that the proof
is in the pudding yeah this is the
products i've been using your skin is
pretty yeah and so honestly she could
have been like oh be an affiliate like
you know whatever she hadn't like
packaged it yet so she do you want to
like be the face of this so obviously
uh at 5050. we're 15 yeah she's really
good and i and anyways i don't know why
i said that but but she's really
she's really good um it's you know
female owned small business she but
she's been around for a while glo is
going to hand my charlotte wilson i use
this stuff like it helps all skin it
really does help all skin problems i
found her through my makeup artist
because i had really horrible like skin
i'm a makeup artist elixir miracles.net
skin.com i have a commercial out now
wait what is it one more time
dot com oh my commercial real quick wait
trish skin trishkin.com that's a really
good domain trishkin wait can i continue
trishkins can you go showcase my
commercial real quick it's like a minute
long it's a minute long it's on my
youtube page oh sure i just posted it
today because we did a whole like this
i'm really proud of this commercial too
okay so a lot of people were like did
you spend a million dollars on the
commercial so you can never possibly
make any money from this because i
believe in it i just like to make it so
funny i love that i love your business
uh oh that's a good thumbnail let's go
okay i'm proud of that all right
everyone get ready
oh my god it looks like a lifetime
moment
a lifetime like a lifetime movie about
like i've overcome all the problems or
maybe it's like a safe donate to save my
dog no it's not there my dog is in this
though he's in this game okay here we go
hi hi trisha
and you may know me as the internet
sensation from such videos too quiet i
don't want to miss a word okay sorry
i'm looking at you dan
my ugly pizza face and help my acne
practices
but acne wasn't the only thing holding
me back in life
well
actually it was i'm 33 and i've
struggled with acne was the only thing
holding you back in your life yeah and
now i'm clear oh now i got dry skin
holding me back that's because i'm
amazing oh brother
i don't don't ask me for the list of
everything else holding it back nothing
this is it i really got cleared once i
cleared my skin my soul my energy and my
chakras were cleared
me my entire life be it my awful diet
stress or just oily bad luck get it out
of control until i found my seven piece
miracle patis miracle elixir in
partnership with charlotte wilson
founder and ceo of glow skin we love you
charlotte
we found the miracle combination to work
on any skin type over the past year we
oh
making like custard what are you baking
them by there
trish is in the laboratory
she doesn't we obviously threw that back
away because i was contaminated but she
does make everything oh you threw that
away trying to show what we're doing in
la like we're just that it's
manufacturing wait why did you throw it
away because now it's contaminated
because it's an air you know it's open
air so for anyone being like oh like it
was just for like the visual that we
make oh
there's kids in africa that could have
they literally can't eat that you cannot
eat the skin product i can't believe
you've thrown that out there's kids in
africa they have action oh my god they
could have used that formula to help
with all hormonal skin conditions
guaranteed to leave you feeling
moisturized without the grease this is
great and controlled without the dryness
just flawless hydrated healthy skin pain
i'm ready to run this on like fox news
at 2 am we have 30 second clips of it so
it's almost done we got a little letter
that's changed my life whether i'm
filming on my kitchen floor or shooting
a music video i no longer worry about my
skin
it really feels too good to be true but
it isn't it doesn't leave any harsh
effects on my skin and i feel confident
with no makeup i want everyone to try
this because everyone deserves that
confidence that comes from this is
really long treasure
55 seconds
here
this isn't like the tricia
skincare episode we do teddy fresh every
single day but i'm so fast
i go okay
we're done but this is awesome i made a
whole cinematic universe around my
skincare
there's 25 seconds left i look forward
to my skincare routine every morning and
night this is your self-love oh my god
was that sexual
look you're like oh like there's like a
it was like a money shot watch this
no look at this this is a money story
skincare routine everything so she
scores this [ __ ] this is
oh yeah i didn't know this was rated r
rated nc-17 look at this this is your
self-love in a bottle the facial rose
that's what you put on your face people
be like trish you're glowing recently
and this is the secret i'm so happy to
finally also kind of phallic what you
say trish what's the secret and then you
show like a foul it looks like a [ __ ]
balls and [ __ ] what are you talking
about look two balls and a [ __ ] it's
like a giant ballast god it's the
products in the throat oh it's literally
a penis
you are so
sorry
look at that that is literally like i
can't believe you did that after the
money
[Music]
it's so much like a penis though
let's just keep going oh dude
this is so this is so inappropriate
i'm so happy to finally be sharing it
with everyone no more hiding behind
filters or photoshop you don't need it
bring the miracle home at yourskin.com
get it right get it tight and get at the
trishway okay i have to call you out
what
you said you don't need to hide behind
filters but you definitely photoshopped
all the comments we're calling it out so
we did put a filter to make a glow but
my skin was really good on the shoe but
but and i agree maybe we should have
like heavily filtered it but
but i can show you my skin right now
like i could take no you have nice skin
no you i vouch for it i vouch for you i
just think it's funny that you said that
line and your face looks like like
heavenly and jelly on that but can i say
the comments but your skin is nice i
vouch for that and everyone can say that
the ingredients are good like
aestheticians are commenting on my thing
and being like oh [ __ ] like the
ingredients are actually good because a
lot of people get cancelled for like
making like like not
poisonous yeah right so everyone's like
huh what who was it that made mold uh
yeah
who had mold or [ __ ] was it awesome
broom's wife no it's someone else
because i know austin groom's wife just
got canceled for skincare like this is
like someone who does this for a living
and i just like use it and like no no no
i i think it's just ironic that you said
that while using a filter that being
said i do vouch for the product because
i've seen it look for you so i don't
don't get it twisted soon well i showed
it on my tic toc too like my face
without makeup i'll do it next time is
there jizz in your makeup if i don't
make a point
in your makeup
is there semen in your makeup no because
there's this really some non there's
like really over tones of penis and jizz
i'm gonna get the commercial that's not
filtered because honestly it looked
really bad
yeah i'll get it
i'm living proof your skin can clear no
matter the issue
miracles happen at trishkin.com
what are you waiting for don't go one
more day feeling insecure about your
skin life is too short let mine your
collection do the work so you don't have
to
yay
congratulations
i'm happy for you i hope it does really
well i and i think it's a good product
based on how i've seen it
like you know what i want to put it out
because i know people if you have a [ __ ]
product everyone's going to talk about
it they're going to put on tick tock
yeah
they were so quick to cancel so i was
like really i really all right you
better pray this girl knows what she's
doing no 100 i've used this no mold or
weird balls and chips no my makeup
artist user my user like she's really
good it just sucks that my skin's like
peeling tape but if i have a makeup wipe
i would take it off right now because my
skin won't be bomb but yeah trishkin.com
guys check it out it was you know it's
that so congrats thanks
okay let's talk about teddy fresh for
two hours i'm just kidding
we talked about it for about two hours
every time you mention it it's like
everybody's just kidding congratulations
it was jaclyn hill by the way i just
yeah jaclyn hill what happened with her
she sold like lipstick that other gold
and [ __ ] yeah we're team jaclyn now we
are yeah i remember i was like kind of
uh but now i'm team jaclyn i guess
apparently
i mean whatever you say you just tell me
who to hate and do it like
we don't we don't need anybody actually
i'm really hateful today so i need to
like reign in the positivity because i
have a lot of hate in my heart right now
i need to like gabby i think just in
general i've been feeling really
negative like when those people were
around my car i just was feeling
negative i felt naked i got you you're
like you know give me some space you
little [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] well it's
also because i
do you know what i'm saying but i also
like when i don't get i am a human being
when i don't have to when i have to do
my own makeup i feel really ugly so i
just feel like with my skin peeling my
own i just don't feel myself like i
usually look at the monitor and like
stare at myself and i just don't feel
like looking at myself no you look good
you're tripping well you're just saying
that you think like anyone looks good
you're just like oh yeah you could say
like alfredo looks good you know alfredo
does look good why are you insulting
alfredo
yeah well why would you say alfredo okay
sorry i don't know where anyone i do
love alfred all right all right so
anyway i mentioned the name of the
person who's we finally ready to talk
about gabby hannah today okay
no not unload but i think it just needs
to be addressed because like literally
no one in her life is like telling her
to stop and i just do we thank our
sponsors oh shh oh sorry we did what up
start and quip we mentioned upstart and
quip our two sponsors upstart
just now i don't remember if i said i
don't think you did i don't think i did
either okay well i'm starting quick
we're just not listening to dan today
because i didn't hear
gov
[Laughter]
all right go ahead so should we talk
about this or should we because i've got
a lot of other stuff i was going to
build up to this yeah whatever i mean
it's it's it's honestly wait what about
the maybe you guys should um
uh set up the sketch real quick okay
yeah we're gonna act yeah okay so we're
doing a scene from the addams family
values that's the sequel adam's family
values awful oh stop it
and i am playing uncle fester who's
wedded the beautiful debbie
little does he know debbie is a serial
killer known as the black widow that
murders her husbands for their wealth
don't spoil it
well you need some context
don't spoil about a 30 year old movie
played by joan cue second christopher
lloyd you actually just looked normal
when i saw you i wasn't like wow i just
like kind of like normal that looks like
yo this looks like you
thank you but you're also skinnier than
the last time you played uncle fester so
that's why it threw me off i was like
wait that looks like narrow like you're
very tiny now really you think i look
narrow well anyway let's go do the scene
and we can come back all right
ethan sits alone at the dining table
waiting for tresha
happy anniversary debbie
house explodes goes up in flames
[Music]
help help
ethan emerges from flames with platter
okay
well okay here i come out of the flames
sweetheart did you get the champagne
freeze
trisha pulls out the gun points at ethan
i try to make it look like an accident i
try to give you some dignity but oh no
not you
i'm sorry go ahead do it dude
okay okay
what are you saying
i want you dead and i want your money
but
don't you love me
treat that
evil laughs i'm sorry oh what
oh moses
is that a no
oh do i love you look at yourself you're
the missing link you shouldn't be
married you should be studied you're a
big dumb weird thing no woman in her
right mind could love you
trisha get hits by a car
and then ethan gets rescued but are not
ethan uncle fester gets rescued by thing
and he says thing
one
take oh uh one other thing welcome back
hope you guys enjoyed that cinematic
masterpiece oscar goes to
trish
i mean i feel like if we did my cosplays
like i'll act like my ass off you know
what i mean like i'll really just tell
me what you want
moa
theodore's birthday party
yes you guys came with some fire gifts
too yeah we did well because like i
picked out gifts and then moses picked
out get so what were you like and i was
kind of worried because at first like
theodore really was pulling for moses as
gift he was like loving that water
cannon i was like oh no he doesn't like
mine because i went with the clothing
which is not good for two-year-olds but
the boots he did come with the booth
they kept him on and then he loves them
you want to take the boots off he's like
no and i was like she got him uh
lightning mcqueen from cars right yeah
uh rain boots he has these yellow boots
that he loves to stomp around and so
that was a great one that's why i saw
those yellow boots and i was like
so i saw a picture you guys sent her in
the group chat and it was him like
wearing the boots with the gardening
glove it was so cute oh do i have that
photo you guys just do that just to show
people like oh look he's wearing it no
no no he was wearing it he was rocking
it i know people i would do that because
i saw that photo i was like oh it's so
funny it was so cool
i don't think i think it was in the
group chat
no whatever yeah but it was really cute
yeah it was a fun day
yeah i look fat in the photo but that's
fine i was just happy to be a part of
the the group
you want me to remove it no no no i was
really excited to erase my special
memory because that was the day i was
going off on buzzfeed so everyone
thought i was in a bad place so i like
that it was shown that i was in a happy
place because i was with you guys so it
you know i have a fat face it's like a
up angle but whatever it's fine i was
happy i was happy i was included and
then the other thing we're going to be
start doing a new segment on the show
frenemies advice corner or maybe it
should be like dr ethan and dr ethan and
uh
psychic trish
well i don't know like who's these
people that give psycho psycho i do did
you know schizophrenia is a psycho
disorder there's like borderlines of
personality disorder and schizophrenia
is like a psychotic disorder right
it's i think it's psychotic so
i'm with you there i think it's a
psychotic disorder i have both which is
crazy so you are so trisha the psycho
and ethan the
yeah psychic
psychologist
well you're awesome i don't know if i
qualify for that maybe you're like just
a you're a college graduate we just oh i
ethan the college graduate yeah that's
more crowd than me i know a lot of
people who graduate from college are
dumb as hell well i never graduated from
college and i'm smart as hell so
well we need credentials to give people
advice you're a college graduate you
have a best friend what's yours that
you're psychotic i have mental disorders
too okay i have a psychological don't
listen to us
which is good disclaimer yeah okay so
the psycho and the psycho and the uh
the uh bachelor of
arts
bachelor of arts
as little qualifications you could
possibly have so um if you guys want
advice for anything you can email us at
frenemiesadvice
gmail.com we've got some new some a
couple of in here that i thought maybe
it'd be interesting to get your takeover
on the top of the show right now right
here it's kind of the end of the show
like we need to talk about news i like
drake bell getting arrested why not
james charles the logan paul fight like
whatever else we want to talk about this
is just like you want to move it i mean
i already set it up though let's just
move it to the end because i don't know
if this is the most important thing we
need to talk about today i was prepared
today
i was i was mentally preparing to talk
about triggers all right
i won't [ __ ] your uh your [ __ ] up yeah
today we've got a special treat because
trish has come in she usually doesn't
want to talk about gabby hannah
understandably because she's up today
because when you feed like stalker
people that are people i should say like
this kind of like attention that's what
they live for like this girl so wants to
be connected to me and now it's giving
her she's going to be the yolanda to my
selena i feel it one day it's not going
to be good
jefferson movie death of a cheerleader
peter mon i'm giving him credit for this
and the thing but there was a movie tori
spelling and there was a girl that ended
up it was based on true story she's like
why won't she be my friend and then she
like stabbed her to death oh you think
gabi's gonna stab you i'm not saying
this lightly but like it really is scary
like the obsession like the the little
lies that she says to be like we were
friends we were friends and i'm like
it's just scary because i don't know
what i did to her other than like i
didn't want to be her friend like and i
was nice to her my theory is that she i
think she's like a super fan of yours
and she like yeah well that's for sure
that's and i was nice to her and then
like obviously when she told jason i had
her because i stopped i still was nice
to her but i was like didn't see myself
but she swore to me that we like hung
out we had like thanksgiving plans we
shared poetry together and then she like
told me the next day after the podcast
like girl i know you never wrote a poem
and sent it to gabby never and never and
that's why even now i'm doing a 12-part
series exposing chart i'm like i've
never been doing a 12-part series about
you yeah literally you should just stab
her and get it over with gabby oh
seriously i can hear her yeah i mean
right let's just let's just cut to the
chest oh my god maybe if she stabbed me
and i don't die you know and then that
way she can be locked away because she
is scary like and and i think she knows
this like her delusions are real she was
like she
was like harassing a 12 year old like
recently for his information because she
thought it was a grown adult harassing
her and she's like give me your
information give me this and the 12 year
old's like okay but he was like and she
was oh i was wrong she like admits that
she's delusional and no one's getting
her help supposedly she has a boyfriend
and all these friends and it's like well
no so that's the only reason i'm saying
this is like seriously she needs help
like point blank period like there's
just i mean
i don't know what else to say but it is
scary i went on her podcast this year
because i was trying to like amend
everything jacqueline how i apologize i
was i was surprised when you went on her
podcast i was like wow yeah because i
was like you know what enough times
passed and like whatever like when i
feel like
you bury the hatchet yeah but sometimes
you know i'm i because i'm pretty and i
feel like when you meet people in person
they're a little more like they're not
as you know like when i met you you know
everyone's just like a little more like
reserved in person they're not but i'm
like a saint when you meet me you
realize that i'm actually like a saint
well you're also just like not
a psychotic person yeah like before and
after i mentioned
yeah because i feel like um well you're
not a saint but maybe oh no i'm i'm you
say i'm a saint
no you're not the same but you're nice
you're really nice and like but i am too
when i meet people even if i disagree
with them like i'm nice i wouldn't like
you know what i mean i wouldn't just
start making a bush that whole podcast
moses was with me it was six hours i've
heard just like convincing me we're
friends convincing me things happen that
didn't and i was just like i don't know
what to say so i was nice nice nice
until the end i had to be like i don't
know what to say like this never
happened like how long into going to her
house for that podcast were you like
this was a huge mistake
about it about two hours into it she was
really nice like i'm telling you when we
first got there super normal we got
there she had domino's pizza for us oh
sugar cookies that we talked about in
front of me is like she really like new
and i was like this is nice and she was
pretty chill like this is cool we're
doing this i want dominoes so bad it
doesn't deliver here i wish we could
yeah i wish we could but we can send
someone to get it we've got employees i
just remember moses [ __ ] gabby i want
dominoes okay let's get dominoes but
what's fine cheese
who's getting dominoes are you serious
dude i'm serious with the heart i'm as
serious as the heart attack i'm gonna
have in 20 years no you're actually
you're actually skinny so maybe the
workout's helping you you need to eat
more like now that you're working yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm at a calorie
deficit right now
we have a whole segment with snacks
you probably don't want to eat the
access food and we're not going to get
to it there's a lot of it though
we got to get to that that's so great we
have a segment coming up
can you show a clip like show a shot of
all the snacks we have we have weird
like uh
what's a way to say that's not
insensitive foreign
i don't know i feel like it's like don't
make us other it's like i don't know
what to say they're yeah they're from
overseas overseas
snacks weird bizarre exotic snacks that
will freak you out
some of them are some of them are
unquestionably weird it's not offensive
thank you cancel dan you'll see
yeah he just said their culture is weird
oh geez okay i didn't say they're called
they're fired i said some of these
snacks are weird we don't tolerate
xenophobic conversation is cancelled
it means you hate foreigners or are
afraid of foreigners me
yeah i used to be scared of moses when i
would wake up in the middle of the night
i used to like literally for seven
months i would wake up and be like oh my
god who was next to me like i would be
terrified like when we moved into this
new house like a disassociation maybe
yeah it was so scary i'd wake up i'm
like oh my god that's why i'm scared if
i get if i get pregnant it'd be like
waking up me like oh my god like what is
in me like i wouldn't yeah but you got
used to moses right yeah yeah we had to
move to the new house to be used to him
but
the bad well you had bad vibes at that
old house with all the weirdos yeah yeah
i think you're right about that but
anyway sorry to do real but let's get
some dominoes can we get some dominoes
please i mean you guys think this is a
game if you want us to move on somebody
gotta shake their tails and get some
dominoes rattle your dags
do you know they say that in new zealand
what's next they say rattle your dags
because there's a bunch of sheep in new
zealand and they have they call them uh
they call them dags when they have
little dried poop at their butt hole why
why dags they just call it tags and so
when they say quickly they say rattle
your dags because the sheets they're
little poop nuggets rattle when they run
fast oh rather your dags that's cute
that's only in australia
new zealand oh same thing okay guys can
we get some movement over here
oh my gosh
can we rattle our dabs please do you
guys think i'm kidding
ah
okay
you guys not even listening literally
like what you're all fired
you should just hire someone since we
have it in the budget just to go get
pizza for us like that they're the
dominoes person they should just have it
i mean we have two people here no but
they're working on stuff like their
production
we need santa has volunteered to go get
it sam's also production she's helping
putting together a theme sam are you
busy
she's
she's she's prepping this ian what are
you doing he's also prepping you guys
are prepping snacks they're prepping
they're busy apparently yeah
that's what i'm saying we should hire
someone just for domino's delivery i
have two employees here i mean they're
busy so we need another i guess for the
dominoes dominoes you need to deliver to
our house why doesn't it that's so weird
you're in l.a
i'm moving
yes oh my god he's like the hardest
working not at the heart but equally
ian's the hardest working kind of he's
doing a lot you're
olives
hawaiian
i've spoke like a [ __ ]
stroke victim hold on let me try that
again oh my god black olives pineapple
jalapenos thank you
this was your idea
literally and now but you're not
rewinding wait hold on hold on you were
so down and now you're acting like i'm
crazy but don't think it was my idea i
was like someone go get pizza right now
i mean i'm down i'll always eat pizza
it's a snack it's a bonding experience
yeah
i feel like you should eat before
because then you have more energy i mean
i did not eat this morning either for
the record so i guess i am hungry i'm
energetic i'm just getting like crazy i
just get a little [ __ ] like crazy
because you worked out this morning no i
didn't even oh really because i do hair
and makeup
tomorrow i will all right okay so gabby
oh oh it's a break okay back we've been
like clickbaiting this gabby [ __ ]
all right we gotta do we gotta do ads
we'll be right back and talk about gabby
hey guys it's just me doing the ad reads
because we had a little bit of a
blowout i don't know how you say a
little fight
blow up isn't a blow up when a baby has
like a massive diarrhea and it goes out
of their diaper i think that's a blowout
which is not what we had we had a little
fight
and uh she
left
at the end of the episode so
i'm gonna be doing these uh ad reads by
myself today thank you um
today was sponsored by
uh
uh upstart
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle high
interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keep you in an endless
cycle of debt well upstart can help you
get ahead upstar is the fast and easy
way to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike the other lenders upstart looks
at more than just your credit score like
your income your employment history this
means that they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners
and with a five-minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars you can receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan so find out how offshore can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com
frenemies that's upstart.com frenemies
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan applications remember go to
upstart.com
fredemies
all right so quip thank you for
sponsoring us there's a script here for
trisha and me so i'm going to be doing
both parts today
trisha says hey guys remember ethan and
i were competing for who could raise the
most money with our favorite quip
toothbrush
i gotta promote trisha's pink toothbrush
now even though i want mine to win and
she's not here we just had a fight
the pink is cool don't get me wrong
but i'm not going to sell it because i'm
the black toothbrush guy
clip is no danny she's they're donating
10
of all black electric toothbrushes and
the all
pink electric toothbrushes to the
charity of our choice
we have an update on who raised the most
money trish this is trisha's line now
trisha quip quip has donated over
i don't know
uh jeez quip has donated over 25 000
combined to lgbtq plus non-profits that
is amazing and i'm sure if trisha was
here she'd be equally amazed by that
the trevor project and national center
for transgender equity
wow and ethan now this is me just by
myself i say and drum roll please
trisha and her all pink electric
toothbrush have raised the most money
wow
and now we want to tell you about the
coolest new way to keep your breath
fresh for pride month
and how you can get a free refillable
gum dispenser yo they got these gums
that i've been munching on
first of all did you know that gum is
great for your ola health it cleans your
mouth
it's got to be sugar-free gum let's make
that clear which this is but these
dispensers are amazing watch this
oh can you get that i want the dog to
get it
here get ready for this watch this
look at this
this is freaking awesome dude
cheers look at this big ass nice looking
gum
pure health
love that gum
the quip refillable gum dispenser and
gum refills is a new way to chew gum
which is even more important now when
we're unmasked and starting to be social
again let's get that breath fresh
you know what i mean the men the metal
clip refillable gum dispenser comes in
all different colors including all black
you know we love it
here's how it works you just easily add
in the gum refill into the dispenser
it pulls out i'm assuming yeah just like
that it's like a pez dispenser
and it takes one click on the dispenser
to pop out each gum
and i personally love the way the gum
tastes it tastes really good minty
super good for your teeth so if you're
looking to freshen up your breath i just
got yourself like clean your mouth you
know
gum all day
i didn't know this but dentists actually
recommend chewing sugar-free gum like
whip scum after meals plus the gum has
xylitol which is a natural substance
that can help prevent cavities and is
accepted by the american dentist
association
the best part after you get the
dispenser it refills the refills are
automatically delivered with free
shipping on your preferred schedule and
refills cost as low as one dollar and 78
cents per 10 piece of gum costs less
than normal gum in the store and you can
be proud to put it out and put it in
your box your bag or pocket
and we got a crazy good hookup right now
you can get a free all back black metal
gum dispenser when you sign up for
refills that's right you get a free all
black metal gum dispenser and all you
have to do
and then you will have fresh breath all
summer long let's get it
all you have to do is use the code fresh
boy 2000
five
we're trying to figure out decode this
the code is fresh boy 2005 i get
quipped.com is this a reference to teddy
fresh or sad boy or is it a combination
of both well it's definitely sad boy
but whether or not it's a teddy fresh
reference or it's just referring to
having fresh breath i think it's an
homage to trisha and it's just like
she's the sad boy and you could be the
fresh boy there you go with quips
amazing beautiful gum
equipped.com just go to uh
g-e-t q-u-i-p dot com
and use code fresh boy 2005 to get a
free all black metal gum dispenser
that's get quip dot com with code fresh
boy 2005.
we're back thank you for waiting gabby
hannah gabby give me a go
i just get scared already because she's
like she thought we'd talk about her
every episode mentioned her like oh yeah
she said she did have a great take on
twitter she goes she messaged me
directly on twitter she said ethan since
i'm a reoccurring topic on your show
i was like she was i don't think i don't
remember one time talking about she said
she wanted to come on and educate you on
neuro neurological disorders i'm trust
me i don't need any education on
neurological disorders i'm a living
[ __ ] i'm a living specimen
well she's blaming all this according to
buzzfeed on her adhd that her delusions
and stuff she thinks it's adhd related
that's her thing but i don't know i
don't
i'm not an adhd expert so i'm not going
to speak on it but i have seen a lot of
people saying that they have it and they
don't act like they don't like that
portrayal of it they're not dilute like
delusions is one thing yeah one from a
different thing my my uh armchair theory
my armchair diagnosis based on no
qualifications at all but knowing people
who have bipolar is that like it can
make you go maine have mania moments of
mania it seems like she's having she
swears that she says it's a troll but
it's not because she's
also it's not getting attention like no
one's watching her videos no one cares
like my views are up i'm getting
millions of views it's like she [ __ ]
on a girl for having 4 000 views on her
video when her podcast gets 20 000 views
i'm like girl like yours is not any like
why it's just anyways there's a lot
delusions also happens it is also a
symbol of a man
oh yeah yeah for sure absolutely i'm i'm
yeah
but anyway the reason we're actually
talking about this is because buzzfeed
did an article
but with interviewing gabby hanna and in
the article the article's called why is
everyone so mad at gabby
and she's addressing some of her
controversy and stuff but here's where
it gets really weird she said this
apparently about you i guess it wasn't
specific but i think everyone concluded
before we get into that can i just say
one thing the reason i the reason i did
get so triggered is this the same person
who wrote this the author came to
interview me at my house and was
supposed to do an article on me and
that's why and i had asked the author to
not include me associated with gabby and
vice versa and i sent her an email on my
birthday may 8th because the interview
is may 7th and she's like yeah of course
because i said it really was like
triggering me at the time it still
really does because it's like how do you
fight delusions like it's just scary
when someone's obsessed with you and so
i said can you just not put me in
because i know talking about her just
like it fuels that she like she she's so
cute
if she interviewed did you know she was
doing an article with gabby no it was so
weird so
i did but not at first you were saying
don't include anything i said about
gabby in the interview because she came
to my house which is fine she came to my
house i had such a good experience she
was asking you questions about it right
oh well then that that's and no
interview i've ever done has ever been
about gabby every interview get well
this is the only interview he's ever
gotten but like it was all you know she
talks about other people in hers but i
never i interviewed about gabby so she
started asking me right away and i was
like oh no and it felt weird anyways and
then at the end she's like off the
record she started talking about gabby
again and i was like as she left she was
there four hours this buzzfeed girl and
i looked to moses my mom was also there
and i was just like something did not
feel right about that like because she
came with she came with an ulterior
motive she's like no gabby's just a
troll she's not like but she did this
this and this like she was convinced
like i don't know if they're friends i
don't know what the situation you know
what the interview they did with gabby
was before it was before oh weird yeah
it sucks too because i had a photo shoot
with buzzfeed this week and i was like
so excited the pictures are gonna be
gorgeous but i was like i just don't
want to be associated even if they cut
everything out about gabby i was like i
don't want this person writing my
article because also the article is just
all so shitty written so i was like oh i
really don't want this it just gave me a
bad taste like the next day before i
knew any of this stuff about gabby
anything the next day i was like on my
birthday i woke up i was like i had so
much anxiety like can you please just
like omit anything about gabby vice
versa i don't see anything bad when i
was she interviewed me it was at the
time where
you don't want her in your narrative
yeah and i and i know regardless of
gabby says she was she's like manic
something seriously is wrong with her
where either she's gonna hurt herself or
someone else so i wasn't trying to like
push her like a lot of people are like
and taken i wasn't trying to push her i
literally was like whoa like this is
like a really serious situation so she
asked me i was like this is someone
who's so clearly people have said this
about me and they were right on on the
internet as like someone that's really
untreated for real she's she has issues
because she's she's not she's not well
she like she lies and then the next day
says that it didn't happen there's like
something not wrong like that's just
facts that happened to me so with her
and so
i just i saw the article come out and
the way and then she mentioned me which
i like triggered but also the fact that
everything so you can read it everything
is like lies at the same time you
couldn't fact-check she rachel oates is
another girl that gabby had some issues
with and the author said about rachel oh
it's like none of this information could
be verified because gabby made all these
claims about rachel oates and the author
was like we can't verify this but for me
she didn't give me that and she didn't
even reach out which is ironic i mean
it's not ironic it's unprofessional
because she went to your house after
that interview yeah and she didn't
specifically say gabby said this can you
yeah confirm or deny it no
phone call for unprofessional well
everyone's saying like unethical like
poor journalism poor faith bad faith
journalism
yeah
and also she said okay yes she even said
i had the email i showed it what she
said back was like i'll respect your
mental health protect your mental health
i will not talk about you and the thing
and then she did and i was like it was
it was so bizarre it was so crazy i was
like i don't know but but from this
interview i did i just had a bad feeling
right away and i had good experiences
with so many other interviews which is
why i was saying yes to this because i
did all these interviews that were so
positive and so good so i think this
will be fun and it's a photo shoot right
so you're like okay they'll have a
photographer it'll be fun and so what
when she left it was so different than
any other interview where i was just
like something felt wrong because she
was just really questioning gabby and no
one's ever asked me about gabby because
yeah why i'm not trying to be like
rupert like literally she's just not
really that popular anymore for people
to talk about her so i was just like no
one cares they care about david of
course but also let me clarify this too
everyone's like when you talk about
david jason like david and jason i was
like i was friends in relationship i was
in their vlogs for two years gabby and i
met twice for like a couple minutes like
i don't know this girl it's clear to me
that you guys are not friends yeah and i
have i have some actually some proof
here too but that's her whole this whole
thing is just her trying to say we're
friends like that's she's just trying to
[ __ ] with you it's like weird it's weird
like well here she says in the article
that buzzfeed didn't attempt to confirm
with you or to validate this claim at
all they say gabby states imagine you
had a friend six years ago who to this
day is contacting your employers
contacting everyone you know and trying
to ruin your reputation she told me
referring in part to patis oh so she
does specifically
i lost sponsors i lost a record deal i
lost my friends
how can you ruin friendship because let
me just tell you what she's referring to
she started a rumor about me having
herpes and i address it that it's not
true so that's how you lost sponsors
because you told everyone i had herpes
like i didn't say anything defamatory
ever about gabby i said what you said is
not true
you're a psycho leave me alone that's
what i said like that's not she lost how
much did they say they say hannah
estimates between 2019 and 2020 she lost
between 10 5 and 10 million in ad
revenue sponsor deal
and record label contracts it's like her
whole life she's lost her record deals i
mean come on which which says she
declined a name because there is no
record deal because gabby is delusional
the facts she said five to 10 million
dollars in one year i've never made five
million dollars in adsense in 13 years
i've been on youtube five to 10 million
is like big creator money and she's i
mean with peace and love not no i've
been on youtube since 2006. she was i
guess back not not at this point no not
like this level and i've got a minimum
20 million views even though i get 20
million views a month and i have my
highest i got 50 million views a month
for 13 years i've probably made
literally i can check my ads and make my
ads a little but i've let him probably
make two million dollars off adsense in
13 years like my adsense is [ __ ] i can
show you right now lifetime thing so
that's so cool
she says adsense well okay let me ask
you this did you ever contact any of our
employers
no and that's what employers she's a
youtuber what employers she's saying she
had brain what brand deal i don't know
she that's so easily verified i don't
have an employer who has an employer
that's a youtuber i don't know according
to the article she also has a publisher
contact contacting everybody you know
trying to ruin your reputation
well
she's sponsors i don't you know sponsors
record deal and like lost friends so
she's blaming the collapse of her entire
life on you over me doing a video saying
gabby i don't have herpes you're a
psycho leave me alone like that's the
video that's all i said she started the
rumor about me and that's why it's so
frustrating but they should verify this
information yeah shouldn't print that
and it should be easier they should at
least ask you and be like did this
happen and then because patricia stated
that this never happened and you know
and we haven't been able to find any
evidence that it did that's the thing
it's like i've done so many even other
people who get interviewed by magazines
i had a big magazine just call me the
other day to fact check someone else's
interview like people call other people
it's so easy to verify if someone lost
sponsorships it's so easy you see an
email from a company that says yep we're
we're not sponsoring you anymore
whatever but this is so it's so crazy
and what it is is she's everything she
is she says i'm obsessed with her she
says i called her friends she the reason
i made the video she every single person
i hung out with she would call them if
she knew them and be like to should talk
about me what a trish is like she's
super weird
i never made one video about it since
but before that and then she kept
harassing people and then when the
herpes thing came out she posted on
instagram the the text message with my
name and herpes in it and that's when i
made the video i'm like gabby you are
psychotic you've been harassing me for
years like leave me alone this is my
leave me alone and like yeah i guess
it's getting her attention or whatever i
mean but it's all bad i don't think it's
good attention and also no one's really
watching her video still she still gets
like yeah i don't think it's really good
for her that she keeps going on and on
about she's not a troll i think she
should just i think it'd be better for
everyone just to mind their business but
i understand that i'm not blaming you
you've been steering clear of her for as
much as boss humanly possible and i
don't know why she just keeps going on
and it's like it's not helping anybody
because this is nothing again i didn't
do anything to her i wasn't i didn't
know her for any period of time i didn't
do anything to her you know like stuff
i've talked about or like people i have
that have been in my life that have
affected me i talk about because like
they did do stuff to me i i've never
done one thing to her i've never made a
lie up about her i don't know she she
you know what and then you say like when
we were talking about how she's you know
she's what we were saying this just to
[ __ ] with me but when we were there at
the house she was like pulling up tweets
from 2015 like off camera just being
like look you did say we were friends we
did and i was just like it's so it's so
here's a tweet from her
saying specifically trisha isn't my
friend
it's like ish it's like you are when you
when it's good for her and you aren't
when she does so everyone said that
about the herpes thing like if she was
this isn't my friend trisha isn't my
friend
i don't i don't know what year but now i
was friends of her for six years like i
was trisha isn't my friend to text her
out of nowhere and say is this true you
have herpes is very strange i didn't
care if she said he told me in person i
responded in person to talk about it
with her like she said it's not my biz
it's his so i asked so i said
ask her if you care don't if you don't
why she type like a 10 year old i don't
know she's there's something so wrong
anyway she's literally said trisha isn't
my friend so i don't know what to tell
you
i don't i it's just it's just such a
it's just so scary and when i was there
in person too like again she was really
nice at the beginning and it turned
really scary there was a point i just
looked over i remember moses to be like
let's leave let's leave because it just
was like so off camera she would stop
the camera and say let's take a break
let's take a break and then she would
just like
trauma dumping like ball her eyes out
and say this person said this about me
like it was insane and i just i sat
there the whole time she was like i feel
like she has kind of like a weird
paranoia
oh issue too well her harassing these
kids like i know you didn't get this
deep into it but to this day on discords
and stuff like that stuff like no i have
i have good stuff so it's beyond
trolling if she's going into private
discords and like threatening lawsuits
with children like she has like a she's
very paranoid she thinks people are out
to get her which you know what i've
dealt with paranoid myself and you get
medication for it and the fact that
she's not getting like treatment and
just like harassing people like that's
what's so scary and when it goes
untreated like it's the scariest [ __ ]
and it is paranoia just
by definition she admitted it she goes
oh yeah i asked a 12 year old or 13 year
old for this information and then i
found i thought it was somebody else and
then i found out it wasn't now i feel
stupid and i shouldn't have done that
and i was like so that's that's paranoia
she like admitted it's like that's what
you need help with like i just don't
understand how no one's getting her help
like in her real life well you can't
help people that don't want it you know
what i mean unfortunately
gabby said in the article she believes
that the reason she's unable to make a
comeback is because she's held to a
higher standard of other creators in the
article she said she specifically called
out controversial youtubers such as
pewdiepie logan paul and jeffrey starr
and the and claim that gabby is held to
a different standard
because uh she is a woman and views her
treatment as sexist i honestly
believe that it's honestly just because
you're not you're making content people
want to watch yeah i mean you've been
canceled you've bounced back people love
yours oh my god yeah that's it's such a
weird thing because also like what does
she tell to a different standard and
fans
the thing is she's but she's never she
said in the thing like oh i've always
had an issue apology she doesn't she's
even in this article everyone else is
the problem and not her like every
single person who's had issues with her
she's never taken accountability for
anything i think i've said i can't count
how many times i've been in the wrong
and you say it but she can't she can't
see it she's the victim but it's always
that it's like really you're going to
blame it on the whole world being sexist
that you can't bounce back like
pewdiepie logan paul jeffrey star that's
how her brain thinks though because
you're not entitled to anything you have
to work for it dude your content sucks i
mean with peace and love i mean her
content sucks but also she sucks she's
like a really shitty person like a
really [ __ ] person like the stuff the
reason like i mean there's there's all
that stuff like
stop again
and she did a show called escape the
season with joey and his boyfriend at
the time danielle and like he just said
how what a nightmare she wasn't he did a
whole video being like what a nightmare
she was jessie smiles what a nightmare
she was like uh eliza and david what a
nightmare she was and like she thinks
she did nothing wrong she goes oh i
don't know why everyone's attacking me
it's like because you're really she's a
she's she's [ __ ] in real life like she's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] person like it's not a troll
it's like she's a shitty person let's
see
um how i woke up that here's a tweet
just to give all the context oh i can
keep it on my screen right
this is how i woke up on my birthday
morning
uh june 5th in stress and desperation i
emailed buzzfeed not to include me
this is the oh i shouldn't show the
email addresses and stuff i don't think
it shows i didn't show it i posted it
right you're right
i blocked hers out
let's see
so this is after you guys met she's as
nice seeing you i just want to email
this morning this is from you this is
the next day like you're saying please
admit anything about gabby hannah what
you believe her to be a troll she really
affected my mental health back in
january
and blob you're saying please don't
include her in my article yeah and then
i said the second one i was saying like
if you choose to that's fine i'm not
writing to this girl like don't publish
this i'm just saying if you choose to
it's fine i'm like just please leave me
out of it like that's it because i knew
she was writing the article she told me
that you know and but she didn't fact
check anything with me so i was like
what the hell like it was so weird
it just gave me a bad feeling and this
is like immediately the next day so i
was just like you know let's just
because i didn't want to like i didn't
want to put more things to gabby's
credit you know what i mean i mean
so here is the author by the way making
a
tweet she said regardless of the whole
story i think it's insulting commentary
on gabby hannah's appearance who's
saying who's nobody yeah so that's the
thing so everyone well she said let me
read the art she said so the the author
is now saying that commentary on gabby's
appearance is sexist
racist if it's about her nose why is she
jewish
what's racist heart lebanese i guess
oh no okay
so what's why was it racist about i mean
she said and that's what gabby's
argument is is that her nose is she said
i didn't know i thought only jews got
[ __ ] for noses that's why i said jews
people do i don't know okay i don't know
i'm not sure can you just let us jews
have one thing
can i just be the the nose victim people
oh my god you can't demand maturity from
someone and then descend into the
childish spineless critique who are we
demanding maturity from from her why are
you gonna say a whole like
okay whatever but all the comments
you'll see are like nobody's talking
about her appearance everyone's talking
about like her harassing people calling
people
so so this video the under it was
amazing and you're gonna love this so
i'm just gonna play it for you this is a
perfect example of how her perception
how she's so delusional how like in her
narrative
she's the good guy
and living in this cruel twisted world
but in reality you'll see because this
video is so well put together that she's
actually being quite mean and cruel
and then she's making this poor victim
who's she's being unreasonably mean to
uh out
you gotta watch this is amazing next up
to bat is dominic deangelis he had to
come at me on twitter said that i was
the uh worst person he's ever met in la
so let me tell you about the day i met
him so before i met him he played a game
of smash or pass publicly on youtube and
when my picture came up he dehumanized
me and demeaned me you know like a
misogynistic disgusting piece of [ __ ]
who acts as if he could have a chance
with me anyway
now by the way i'll say that smasher
pass is gross it is kind of a gross game
to play like that but she also played it
twice oh she's done it before oh yeah
she said she played with timothy
delagato this youtuber and he said this
girl and she goes oh she's so gross like
it was about she said something it's
such a hypocrite yeah it's a hypocrite
okay so then forget it but okay so this
guy on the left she's saying dehumanized
her okay who says he just pulled up a
sign that said pass
pass
what would you pass on gabby
that's not my type man [ __ ] he just said
she's not my type man yeah that's
literally all in her smashing basket she
said to someone ew she's so gross like
when someone said that they would smash
her so she like but wait it gets way
better than this right so watch this so
at a party he approached me like nothing
was wrong and i confronted him about it
and i said i didn't like that and he was
like oh come on it's just games and i
said well you're too short for me to
[ __ ] how do you like being judged on
your physical appearance and then he
stormed off and didn't like me anymore
you [ __ ] nasty piece of [ __ ]
so she thought she really did something
but now again this is so good because
they have footage of exactly the
interaction at the party
oh yeah let's talk about it this is the
guy
i did so you mean to tell me that if
tonight
we got a little bit drunk and i was like
hey i'm really interested in you you
think you're out of my league
i don't say you're out of my league
no honestly i'll do anything when i'm
drunk
you just want your job no the fact that
i'm three inches taller than you is that
the reason you're a little intimidated
so she's trying to like tear him down at
his core like short guy i'm gonna [ __ ]
you up psycho it's like the good the
dude literally just said you're not his
type and he's being nice to her here
this one in person he was like okay
we're cool whatever totally and she's
like well you're three interested like
who says that to someone in real life
like that exactly and so like exactly
this is exactly why i could totally
understand why he doesn't like her i
mean this is just so inappropriate and
then you're sick and your fans out after
him being like oh this guy's a massage
he literally just said you would you're
not his diet and you also played this
game badly twice like you can't you
cannot beat
he's just being nice he's like maybe
maybe
so that so like that's
because what are you gonna say to
someone in real life no i don't want to
[ __ ] like it's just being nice i don't
ask somebody that oh it's so pretty i
don't know
i can't wait wait i gotta watch this and
then she says
hang on she said something about like
nobody knows who you are
yo it's fine nobody on my blog
oh yeah she and then she hit someone
that nobody knows who you are like she's
some big time
i literally had never like i didn't know
i thought that was like i thought that
clip was great because it really shows
the distortion of reality
it's so crazy but that's what i'm saying
like it's just there's facts that she's
a delusional person and it's just like
it's just scary it's just really scary
here's another one
gabby calls uh
called malignant malignant narcissist by
journalists who analyzes moments in
gabby's bud feed profile when she asks
everyone about most embarrassing moment
journalists goes on to describe it as
forced into intimacy to hold others at
emotional gun point
so the first part of the article was the
author said right when she walked in the
room gabby asked everyone to say their
most embarrassing moment
like without like everyone was there and
then that girl was saying like that's a
really that's this other art person was
saying that that's like emotional
blackmail it says okay hannah hannah
turned to us and said okay this is a
question for everyone in the room what's
your most embarrassing moment and even
though she hadn't met any of us before
including her new publicist who at no
point during the day would allow me to
speak to hannah alone we answered one
told her about a recent blackout another
about an awkward interaction with a
crush and you hannah asked me so wait
who was this sort of this person then
just a random person she didn't know who
gabby was this person has no idea what
gabby is she just commented on like uh
she's not random she's like a she's a
reporter for something
or writer for something one thing a lot
of women really need to watch out for is
this technique of force intimacy in
women's spaces where essentially the
goal is to have enough compromising
information to hold others at emotional
gunpoint it's manipulative and you
should stay distant from it this is
unpopular in the u.s but accepted in
europe you should share your most
personal information with people you can
trust take note people dig for your
vulnerabilities while ignoring your
strengths they're looking for emotional
leverage raise the bar
for you just commenting on like
something on buzzfeed but
it'd be fun to show everybody the
friendship that you said didn't [ __ ]
oh that so then this is her threatening
you with i god knows what she's saying
from like 2016.
she's saying here can you turn it up dan
so this is when you keep saying we're
not friends we're not friends and this
is when i had my i did have like a
really bad episode so i had like
schizophrenia diagnosis on in january of
this year and i was kind of cool that
this was right before medication i i
really had to get medication after this
because i was like holy [ __ ] like it's
because she's like i have these texts
from you and i was just thinking like
because i have my own delusions with
paranoia at like late as of late i was
thinking like oh my god but then after
like going there's a thing called
cognitive group therapy that i went to
and i have after like going to that i
was like reality like set in and i was
like i've never even
i've never even said like my birthday to
this girl i've never i've never shared
anything with her but she's saying i
shared all these secrets and then all of
a sudden my my brain starts spinning
that way so i have like a breakdown like
i had a cruise making you crazy your
reality yeah and i was like but then
after like really like getting like
stability i was thinking like oh
literally i've never told this girl
anything she's just being she's just
being disgusting like it's just this
really weird troll behavior and i guess
you could call it trolling because i'm a
public figure but when she does this
with other people that are private that
people are like not even in the public
eye like it's it's so she's so scary to
me in so many ways and i'm not just like
i do not say that lightly like she's an
actual she has psychotic behavior and
it's really scary the way she's manic
the way she's like yelling and screaming
and like it's scary her face is very
terrible it's it really is scary
everything about her is terrifying i
should wear a gabby hannah mask on
halloween when we do a halloween episode
i will i will have a heart attack and
i'll have a knife and i'll be like trish
that's gonna happen that's gonna happen
one day i it's awful i just i hate to
say this but i really do think she needs
to be like i wish she would so she'd be
locked away is she unworthy well i know
in your mind and your like own life
story you you were expecting to die
somehow yeah so is gabby a worthy person
to murder you or no no because she'll
get what she wants she'll always be
associated with me if she's the one to
kill me it's like yolanda selena they
always john was killed by some random
nobody it's kind of iconic he got his
own movie jared leto played the killer
right
and same thing with selena like you
can't you know selena quintanilla she
was killed by her fan yolanda that was
the girl who was shot by a fan at like
vidcon or something no no oh that was
christina grimmie oh grandma yolanda
zeldivar was her like a big fan of
selena and she like worked close with
her and she shot her because like selena
didn't want anything to do with her
anymore and now so are you afraid if are
you afraid of gabby kills you you won't
get that biopic
i'm scared she'll be a part of it
because no matter what the killers are
part of it and she's
it it's it's it's scary
like just her i've never had this
obsessiveness by anybody in my life and
it's like really it's really really
scary and i try to ignore it
but with this buzzfeed article i really
just triggered me again because this
person that i let into my house and
interview me like didn't tell me any of
this stuff i was just like what is
happening like then again i started
stuff of that art that off that author
dude especially
my whole interview was about mental
health and like right well something i'm
dealing with with that and then also she
was like congratulating me oh your house
and your businesses and then get all
this so it was like really great and
then when she asked the gabby questions
especially when she went off record and
it's like okay off record she's like
telling me something about gabby and
then something just fell off so the next
the next morning i had anxiety all night
the next morning i was like just don't
mention gabby and mine i don't want to
be mentioned in hers and she wrote back
i won't mention you because i say you
were declined to comment i was like fine
that's fine and then she she put me an
article i was like this
it was crazy it was it was i was i was
really in shock and i was i was really
upset this was saturday and i was really
i was i was manic
i'm glad we're talking about it because
i think it's good for you because i i
feel bad every time you're like you've
got this person that you're trying sore
to avoid i'm glad we're getting it out
there and then i think we should just
like really leave it no for sure i think
and again i would have left it if it
like i guess because it was like the
same article and i didn't know if buzz
because buzzfeed just came to my house
to do a photo shoot this past wednesday
so i was like sure are they going to
still run this article
and i didn't want to email her directly
because i did it before and she like
just disregarded and ignored me and then
and i didn't even mention her on twitter
at the author the author inserted
herself so like that at mention i never
at mentioned her i just said like
whatever and then she inserted herself
and said some [ __ ] tweet but
it is just something that i want to put
out there because again i just this
person is obsessive i've said in
numerous videos like to like leave me
alone and like even the herpes thing the
reason i made the video is i'm like
gabby just leave me alone like you did
the herpe thing stop questioning my
friends why i don't like you this is why
i don't like you that initial video was
why i don't like you gabby and she
couldn't like leave me alone and i've
never i've literally never done anything
defamatory to her nothing calling her
like what friends what sponsors i know
nothing about you like what are you even
doing i feel like there's no way dude
that's just decision that's so but
that's what's so crazy is she thinks
that i have this power to make her lose
10 million dollars in a year like it's
right
but that even that number shows the
delusion that she has even that number
nobody is worried
if i'm like yeah i made 10 million
dollars last year but like i lost it
because of david robert whatever that
number
yeah that's she's she's it's it's really
scary anyway so she put up this video
being like yo we're friends uh and it'll
be fun to show everybody the friendship
that you said didn't [ __ ] exist
because you didn't know me right despite
the fact that i don't know her years of
text messages saved between yeah just i
mean i text with people casually too
that's pretty normal the fact is i don't
mean that we're friends why don't you go
like look for attack how do you even
save perception from 2016. i don't have
messages like how she has these names
because they delete after a while you
get new phones whatever yeah the fact
that she has these all like saved or
even my instagram was like deleted it's
like it's crazy but even the stuff that
she's like threatening me with the
background she doesn't like some
conversation i don't know why
yeah and it's like
what's the threat that we texted i was
yeah i wasn't sure she's just like look
we talked in text one time it's like
okay epic and i was nicer before 2017
before the herpes thing i always was
nicer we never hung out so you don't
have herpes
i would be the first to be like i have i
have cold sores on my lips sometimes
i've never had genital herpes oral
herpes um i guess i don't know i don't
i've never gotten medication for it i've
never gotten very common but no one's
diagnosed me with like hurt when i was
younger i had cold sores but i don't
have i've never had my yeah but i tell
people all the time i've had clematis
cold sores he just put his hand up okay
so i've but i haven't had one in 15
years you know what i mean i don't take
like medication but why would female
people know that anyway
so what she told me and all to say she
said often she's like oh shane told me
that and i was like shane is shane yeah
but you know can i tell you since
shane's been out of my life i really
think he had the evil eye on me for real
because as soon as i you think shane
actually did plant that in her head
i feel like that's a stretch even for
shane i don't think so yeah because i
mean he i guess he supposedly to peter
man he called me like what did he call
me a sociopath or something to peter oh
shane was telling me and [ __ ] about you
yeah what a [ __ ] [ __ ] which is so
crazy i would never speak a bad word
about you and like especially in like
private you know after now after now i'm
sure i said plenty of mean things about
you in private before we became have you
before we became friends i don't think
i've ever seen anything meaningful
i would probably just say like she's
she's a lot or something right of course
i wouldn't be like she's got herpes like
make weird [ __ ] up it's so weird and
it's like the oh is that but the thing
is is like well it's just that sad to me
because i honestly consider shane like
like i never said one bad thing you said
he has his evil eye on you like in what
way i thought he did honestly because as
soon as i i cut shane and rylan off and
i've been seeing like all this nastiness
like i because my life was so toxic when
i was friends with shane he was the only
person that was like there for me for
things but i have to wonder if he's like
putting out like negative energy like
wishing it because as soon as i cut him
off this year in january like everything
like my skin didn't just clear up oh
[ __ ]
it's true it's been a good time for
trisha payton getting cleared up because
that hair by j thing was all in january
that happened when you met me or did it
happen from trishkin.com trishkin you
just launched that
no but no but like seriously my even my
aura my stability in my mind like my my
the fact that i can handle triggers and
like good auras do you know what i mean
yeah and i've got it there i've been
going to therapy since 2019 so you could
say therapy but at the same time i'm
like i really think since like i really
left that like everything's been like so
much better just really interesting yeah
everything like health like money like
everything just like flows friendships
everything because oh well here's
another thing it's kind of gabby when i
went on the podcast
this was in january and at the time
she's like oh would you like a giant
feather in your eyelashes feather should
i take it out yeah
oh okay i got it oh that's so weird
where did it come from okay thank you
for telling me because if you don't tell
me yeah i know last time you got angry
at me no but you had like a little
powder on your face and you got like
super clear on me food or something on i
think anyways it doesn't matter but when
i was on the podcast in january her
podcast she had asked me it was the
friendship thing she was so again moses
are you gonna test anyone could have
tested this even on the podcast she just
she spent so much convincing me that we
were friends and i was like and i even
apologize i said i'm sorry if like you
know i i have to be honest i said it on
the podcast i don't i don't like friends
i don't have friends because i'm really
bad you're friendly you were friends i'm
friendly and i've always said that i'm
like i don't i'm not good at friendships
like i don't want friendships all this
stuff like that so i said apologize to
her she thought like whatever and then
she goes well you're friends with ethan
and ela and at the time this was january
this was the second week in january this
was after our blog on january december
we weren't hanging out because of covert
or whatever you said on the show that we
weren't friends i said i said well i
don't really consider them friends you
know what i don't know what you mean we
don't hang out i don't think yeah we
where we're at the time yeah but then
she goes no you are friends with them
like she spent so much time trying to
convince me that i was friends with you
guys after i said because if you're not
friends with us then her whole her whole
understanding of friendship has gone
more well that's what she said because i
said why don't hang out with that [ __ ]
you don't need to hang out with people
to be friends with them like she was
like going everything had an answer
clearly her definition of friendship is
much different of course and i kind of
agreed to like disagree that because i
said that and i said in her house and
when she was making up these lies and
she wasn't showing me proof i kept
saying show me personally eventually i
had to be like gabby like i'm trying to
be just i'm trying to be respectful in
your house and like but i'm going to say
that stuff didn't happen she was you're
gaslighting me now i said no because
what i really want to say is you're a
psychotic [ __ ] but i'm being like nice
i'm in your house she like didn't get it
she was just and she still doesn't and
like but she is and i mean from one
psycho like psychotic person to another
like she is psychotic there is i have a
psychotic mental illness she has a
psychotic mental illness because she has
proven that she has delusion she's
admitted delusions get help get pills
get something let's watch this video so
this is her threatening you apparently
fun to show everybody the friendship
that you said didn't [ __ ] exist
because you didn't know me right despite
the fact that i have
years of text messages saved between us
i don't know why you lie like this
you're a really really mean malicious
person like i just what are you so
afraid well i know what you're so afraid
of and so will
what the everybody
is that
it's so scary it's like a movie it would
be so funny about the knife she has for
you
i know you'll be scared of and everyone
else will know soon it's called mr
smiley i'm not kidding i'm not kidding
when i say this is literally um it
literally feels like a movie where she
is like getting to kill ready to kill me
because she like cannot stand that like
i don't know it's gonna be a really good
like true crime story i hope i survived
if she stabbed me i just hope i survived
you do you think you'll do like dateline
or like a big time documentary if she
attempts to kill me because if i'm dead
i won't be doing anything
yeah if she's if yeah well either way do
you think it's dateline worthy like 2020
worthy or like real true crime [ __ ] it's
gonna be all over the news i think it'll
be like 2020. let's see that's okay
that's like here i'm not i'm not even
being a little kidding i like don't
leave moses aside like we go everywhere
together because i'm kidding around but
i i i i understand you're concerned it's
just crazy because it's crazy because
she like thinks everything's like a
coincidence like she'll do what i'm
doing and like things so it's she's
scary so wait what do you know what
she's afraid i know what you're saying
behind her
it says something about amish like
amish like you guys are talking about
the amish
she's like bro i have i have evidence
that you don't like amish people
i [ __ ] the amish in their farms
because i'm trying i'm trying to read
like who's
it's like bro have you seen the arm
amish and their wagons [ __ ] amish
pieces of [ __ ]
and maybe in 2016 i was talking [ __ ]
about amish people i don't know
why are you so afraid well okay i know
what you're so afraid of
oh
it shows it a little bit yeah you can't
it just says dead ass amish dead ash
amish or well she wrote that because i
don't say deadass oh so she said deadass
amish maybe i'm saying something you
said oh my god hahaha they they they
lull even that's it because the only
thing you think of is in 2016 i was
dating someone that was like from an
amish family or like so like kind of
amish family so maybe i was talking
about that
you said [ __ ] about the amish but i
don't even remember talking [ __ ] about
amish i think i said oh they're amish
and she was dead you're like bro have
you seen how fast this [ __ ]
could build a yarn little douchebag dead
like are they really amish are you just
saying they act like i think that's what
i don't know i have no idea i'm just
saying like i did i probably have texted
with her and she probably has text
messages but like
i don't know what she's exposing but
like also just imagine being so obsessed
with trying to prove someone's your
friend it's like okay they said you're
not your friend like chill oh my god
right did you see that did you see the
peter man's
video about it let's show that i did
it's really good oh my god he and what's
so crazy she's calling me mean and all
these things it's like okay then why do
you want to be my friend or why do you
want to prove this like i just say i'm a
nasty person and let it be so this was
one of my favorite moments of this
recent gabby saga
so there's apparently she has a
exclusive discord for members or some
subscription model
and there was a group of people that
joined and they wrote a review of her
discord they didn't like it but it was
basically just a review they wrote and
so she goes into their discord not hers
and says you need to contact your
parents because i'm suing you if you
publish that review
for slander so here we go
yeah this is pretty good the interaction
that happened between yeah like he's
trying to understand what's going on
with his does he have a piercing or like
discoloration on his beard i was i was
like so tripped out i was trying to
figure it out
no it's not a piercing that's what's so
uh i mean god bless patrons
no i'm not talking trash i was just
genuinely trying to figure it out
you know
do you have any opinion on that dan i
mean i really was like well i'm a little
confused too yeah i think it is a
piercing though oh you do yeah the
people get that right in the middle of
the hyperlip
anyways i'll get into the interaction
that happened between but why is it like
brown it's like dark brown under it it
also
yeah i don't know it's weird it kind of
looks like a piece of like he blew his
nose and he left a little tissue there
he has like a cleft or something
oh okay okay i don't know okay no no
you're right you're right god bless him
you know i'm just trying to figure it
out
i'm just noticing something and trying
to analyze it but hey this isn't about
him it's about gabby anyways i'll get
into the interaction that happened
between gabby and some ex-patrons now so
gabby starts off saying hey guys i just
wanted to give you a heads up about i
love the b-roll for anger they typing
it's so funny
i don't know but this guy's a legend for
finding this footage the lawsuit and
this member of the discord is obviously
shocked then she follows up with for
those under 18 your parents will be
contacted then this member of the
discord says a person with a big ass
following scaring kids really it's not
about scaring guys it's slander i know
this is funny games for you but it's my
life and again she's you see how far she
takes [ __ ] it's like some kids didn't
like your discord and you're trying to
tell your parents i'm suing you
it's like so scary
this isn't trolling this is now private
off the internet you're not getting
attacked like these are kids these are
yeah like something's really wrong i
paid for your service and then they
wrote a review but anyway now you've
published it publicly she's referring to
the google doc that was posted in her
discord server this is an online chat
honey we know the law ma'am it's not
slander at all if i have proof all we
did was explain our experience on a
private discord that hasn't been posted
publicly on any other platform then
gabby says if you publish to the
internet it's publishing then another
member that gabby angrily typing is the
best meme of the year
it's so awesome
yeah for sure we can't after there's no
steamy nomination for her either we
cannot mention her ever most likely to
assassinate trisha payton stop the
winner is and then we invite her up and
we give her a knife as a reward stop
that's why i bring security i have a
security guard that comes with me
everywhere i'm not kidding she will show
up yeah
most likely to kill trisha with this
knife so scared i'm gonna sue you for
slander there's gonna be a lawsuit i
know she's gonna come for me now i'm
already being sued once honey get in
line
get in line bro
like you want people
to think you're a good person but then
act like that then gabby says i'm not
here to fight i genuinely don't know
where this is coming from or the issue
the bullying that has gone on towards
myself and other patrons isn't right we
never said anything about other patrons
all we did was share our experience and
yeah that's true i've read the google
doc and it's pretty much just like a
review like a review that you could give
any other business then this member says
gabby most of these people you wake up
out of a out of a wait hold on oh my god
you wake up out of a out of a st
stupor
your eyes come too
you look up this is what you see like if
she chloroformed me and i'm just like
they're on the floor wake up you don't
know where you are
you see gabby angrily typing i don't
forget
you can't move
your mouth is covered with duct tape oh
my god
it's so scary like i'm laughing because
i'm trying not to be scared like that's
the only reason i can make it cause i'm
terrified it's funny though no i know i
mean outside of it but like it's
probably gonna happen and i just am like
preparing myself for it let's keep you
safe let's not give her any knifes and
any awards for most likely to kill
trisha thank you yeah no more
okay
thank you this member says gabby most of
these people are kids kids who felt you
didn't hold up your end of the bargain
with the discord and didn't listen to
their ideas we are not bullying i've
only heard information and shared what i
heard and chose to cancel myself amazing
these kids are so much more mature than
her
they're like so mature and like yeah
right just like we just didn't like your
subscription yeah sorry we're just
literally a youtuber with a million plus
followers scaring kids on discord it's
not slander to share our personal
experiences and pictures for the first
time drama channels would be obsolete
drew that then gabby says at the end of
the day this is my server and i am the
admin if i don't implement every change
people want there's nothing wrong with
that
i think she may have forgotten that
she's actually not in her discord server
at the moment she's not her own discord
yeah she's like i this is my discord i
am the admin it's like what that's again
really scary like really this is not
your server you're just coming in here
threatening kids thinking they should
believe the threats then gaby says it's
not a threat don't twist my words i'm
coming in as an adult giving you guys a
heads up it is a threat a lawsuit is a
threat telling them you're going to call
their parents is a threat just because
they're on it bro so she literally
anyway after that because i watched that
full video she said after that she goes
what lawsuit what are you guys talking
about everyone like she said that in the
video as a continuation and it's like
it's cr it's like it's really really
really really scary so anyway i want to
give a shout out to this guy because for
that b-roll alone
sit just see id so if you can watch the
whole video there by sid but shout out
good good channel i think it's just hair
though yeah i think it's grown weird i
think
or something there okay shout out to sid
though we love him sid reach out and
send us that b-roll
oh we need that no
yeah we cannot use it
we'll use it on on off the risk
she tweeted you to being like a fan
being wanting to be on the show and
stuff so you're giving her that
attention don't even move it
yeah okay all right
never mind oh look you're ruining her
career again
i think i could tell my friend let's not
talk about this is a huge opportunity
for gaba to be featured in angry b-roll
i'll straight up tell everybody don't
talk about gabby if he's into her
narcissism like don't talk about her
everybody i'll say i've said it to him
videos i'll say it again don't ever talk
about gabby i'll say it she's she's not
we're breaking your roles right now but
you know what i mean like she's unwell
and people talking about her is
literally just like pushing her to
continue this behavior like it's just
not it's not she's thinking like she's
oh she's in control i'm this master
troll it's like no you're you're a
serious like sick individual like it's
really this was another one this is my
final piece on her
um are these my colleagues this is her
lives
honestly
gabby hannah tick-tock live getting she
got banned during this
one
do you hate who come on
cause i hate who i become
no i know what this is though this is
trolling
is this whole thing she copies my format
to the extreme because now that she had
this manic episode and she had a
breakdown she's trying to like i used to
do that [ __ ] all the time in 2017 like
you know you just like are trying to
like distract people like look i'm
trolling i'm in control but she's not
like that was obviously a troll she's
obviously off her manic episode but
she's still not like well she's just
trying to make people be like crazy yeah
because she wants to be as peterman said
the villain and the victim and she's
like she goes oh yeah i'm always victim
but also like i'm in control i love
being hated i love freddie mercury was
also judged and so i'm like him like
she's just so like delusions like a
grandeur so that that was a troll
but you want to talk so anyway that that
that wraps up our whole thing on gabby
hanno i mean there's just so much more
about her but like i honestly think
anything else you want to add before we
i i will say it to you outside everyone
like to not mention her like this this
person is like sick like a sick sick
person the only time i've mentioned no i
agree and because and i i agreed to do
it because it was about this buzzfeed
article that i was like i trusted like
this author that wrote an article about
me and i thought buzzfeed i guess
buzzfeed has a bad reputation already
which i didn't know everyone's like
they're kind of trash anyways i guess
they steal content from people and stuff
so i think they like have they've always
had a really trash reputation and then
they started writing like real articles
ian's over there secretly eating pizza
what are you doing
dominoes are wrong that [ __ ] over here
um i didn't know that i would have said
but then like like i don't know i they
like keep flip-flopping but yeah they
have a really trashy reputation yeah and
i had i had no idea they a few years ago
opened a a news division that's sort of
separate from their like clickbait
articles and stuff right and we're
trying to get a more legit reputation
but um i don't think it was very
successful and it seems like they've
slid back into just kind of like vanity
[ __ ] yeah
it's really
really bad and i just i don't want any
associates i'll say it again buzzfeed i
want no association please don't put my
article
that author is trash like she did zero
research like she her writing skills are
i should have done more research i
should have done it i will take the
photos though though i had a really good
her name was rosette right oh she
photographed photos from she photographs
from new york times and i was like oh
she was like i just do these randomly
and she's so good she photographed like
natalie portman i'll take the photos i
have some behind the scenes i'll take
the photos but not the article you can
bring yeah you can bring them here
thanks is there phone numbers you guys
get slices
the phone numbers this way so you can't
see it
so you guys know about my pizza thing
people judge me oh i didn't i opened
yours damn
people judge me what do you mean your
pizza thing
the fact yeah what's your pizza is the
pizza thing that if somebody mentions
pizza around you you
flip out until you get some pizza that
is a pizza thing no i got black olives
pineapple and jalapeno and it's insane
so good i like all those ingredients but
together it's just weird right i know i
have i've tried it you don't like it no
it's not good
i feel like we're like
because ela's pregnant like we're all
eating like we're pregnant we all do
sympathy eating with her she's not here
but like here's to you that's why i need
to start exercising more because i'm
going to get
massive oh yeah
you want to do advice column
sure yeah would you we don't want to
talk about drake bell or logan paul
drake bell literally got arrested for
him
uh about 40 minutes yeah what was the
deal with drake ball he i i didn't know
that's a different people
what happened with jake paul he got
arrested i guess um for child
endangerment but what did he do chelsea
was one thing i don't i don't really
understand that one completely but there
was another charge he got and it was
basically just him being inappropriate
like saying inappropriate messages with
a 15 year old back in like 20 seconds
same thing with james charles like why
are you where's james strong's arrest oh
my god how does jake paul get arrested
for one incident but there's been
multiple ones where james charles admits
well hold on he got arrested now for dms
back when in 2017. so that's what i'm
saying it takes time
right that that is the investigation and
it was ohio ohio has different laws so i
guess like ohio's like a little bit
different but like it's insane to me
that james charles is just like
celebrating birthdays and things like
that happened that that just in a year
to the point right knocking it it's well
you know i hope like there are certain
people that like should get canceled
forever and like james charles is one of
those people doesn't surprise me though
right i guess he moved to mexico and
became drink companion and doing spanish
music or something yeah don't judge the
companion
so isn't that crazy from 2017. but i
mean that's good i'm glad that they're
able to do that from like after a long
time because so many people be like why
is anything sooner or whatever but the
girl was like 15 at the time you know
what was she gonna like well you know
these cops like to um make sure that
their arrests and convictions hold so
they
take the time to get the yeah all the
evidence they need i thought that was so
crazy i was just like how could more
people aren't talking about that i guess
that he's just not popular like james
charles or whatever you wanted to talk
about the fight yeah did you watch it
mm-hmm i didn't watch it i just want to
talk about it because i was i don't know
because it's trending i don't know
what's happening in it i watched the
whole thing
paid for it too
maybe we should box you brought up
boxing earlier maybe we should box you
know what
i'm a proud
supporter of show time
they are amazing
on that show proudly
are you okay drinking water
i'm a proud supporter of showtime and
i'll tell you what
what a great show what a great
experience it was to watch showtime
sports
is that the sponsor
no they're just not trailer trailers
awful like compared because trailer put
on the jake paul fight those are the
guys that are suing me oh that's still
happening or no it's done oh they're
still suing me yeah
and so um
their event was just horrible like just
such regret watching that at least the
showtime one they put on like a real
event where the under cars were
interesting fights were good fights
experienced boxers because trailer was
like
trying so hard they got brought out like
all these popular performances and stuff
spent like a fortune which is why
they're going to be going out of
business pretty soon but um it was just
a horrible event
if they do bankruptcy
that's what i was saying i don't know
what's going to come first their defeat
in court or their bankruptcy
it's a toss-up
but anyway it was just there the trailer
boxing event was just so horrible it's
no it's no surprise that jake paul left
triller and joined show time and i think
paul after yeah what yeah he left
trailer
because he realized they're just it's
just a horrible train wreck it's like
titanic and um jason ash is still there
well exactly titanic and it's syncing
with him
and um
you know
it's not and i think he did the right
thing because the show time really puts
on a good experience a good fight and
it's definitely worth the 50 it was a
great experience unlike trailer horrible
experience terrible fight terrible
company but no i watched the whole fight
and i will say um you like it i i do not
understand like
i guess what is the entertainment value
of it i can see wrestling because
there's like a show there's characters
they're in costume
it's boxing like a show he came out to
greatest showman everyone's like i think
of christian faith when i think of this
song the from now on
i was like oh that's kind of cool
i obviously the boxing match itself was
such a ridiculous mismatch i mean
floyd is 44 he's like five eight okay
and then logan is like what 25 he's six
two so when they were in the ring
together the the actual
weight class is insane like these people
should never in any reasonable
world fight
so the fact that floyd didn't knock out
logan or anything doesn't surprise me
because he's just he's not known for
being a striker but he fought well and
and and logan was able to go the
distance so
there was one clip where people saying
uh floyd knocked him out momentarily and
and then he held
logan up
so he didn't follow that okay so i just
saw the jokes about hugging they hug
because someone's almost about to faint
or something so they're holding no logan
kept hugging him because he was
exhausted oh is that why to break yeah
oh i love that i'm gonna start using
that when i'm like winded tomorrow when
we do our vlog i'm gonna hold on to
moses i'm gonna give you a hug yeah
that's what they do
and so mayweather was getting annoyed
though he's like get the f off me dude
oh he's like you're a little baby [ __ ]
basically yeah i mean that's what i
would think he's saying i'm not saying
that about logan he's not maybe
obviously um
floyd kicked his ass in terms of like
the boxing experience like the stats of
amount of punches said and accuracy was
insane
but like when you watch it i guess
what's the entertainment like when
someone hit someone like whoa or like
what's the exciting part of it like it's
the hitting or it's the what well it's a
game of strategy i mean
it's not just about knocking them out
it's about landing punches it's about
dodging punches so it's a sport
just watching two athletes compete did
you see that floyd mayweather were
sponsored by fashion nova on his trunks
he was wearing the only fan's hat really
yeah all this money
yeah his trunks and nova men on him so
fashion nova's been division
he works for anyone that guy is just
there to make that made me think i need
to ask for more money because freshman
would be lowballing me but if you're
sponsoring flight mayweather oh yeah i
think i sell more clothes in floyd
mayweather you know anymore when it
comes to fashion nova i should probably
get away and you know that
mayweather don't wear no fashion no he's
got his rolex they're like
i do wear fashion like i'm not it's not
sponsored but i do wear it every day
like i love fashion nova okay can you
stop talking about all your sponsors i
haven't talked about them in a long time
but
well i thought it was good so you want
to give advice while we eat pizza yeah
can i say one more thing did you ever
see brokeback mountain i watched that
last night i actually never watched it
but i know the plot ah did it break your
heart oh my god it was like cowboys just
wanted to be they just wanted love to be
loved
love is love but it wasn't even that
like the one like could not be with him
because he's like because it takes place
in the 60s 70s and 80s it's like through
the era and stuff like that it's
i can't spoil it can i because it's like
2004 but it's like spoil it oh my god
yeah so
well basically like they they do fall in
love with each other they're both
married to women this takes place in the
60s or whatever and then jake gyllenhaal
gets like beat in the face to death for
being gay in texas and then the wife
played by anne hathaway like i think she
was in on it at the end because she
calls him not much change since then in
texas i don't do i know but that's what
i'm saying that's what's so okay i'm not
trying to get all like about that
there's still people are still like that
like trans people are getting beat in
their face to death
and so like watching it i was just like
holy [ __ ] and like heath ledger jake
gyllenhaal said heath ledger refused to
make like gay jokes about it like during
the oscars and i don't know is there a
third pizza you're so not good about
this okay let's go to here
i don't like this segment just for the
record fan advice is those stupid
segments
it's so dumb what's the point
uh to give advice to our fans but that's
not the like oh no it's that that's like
when people run out of ideas and they
start doing q and a's like tyler green
ideas like we're gonna do q a's now
because we have nothing else to talk
about okay go ahead
it's such a dumb segment it's so not
it's like we have something all the time
okay well what you want to talk more
about uh what brokeback mountain a movie
from [ __ ] like 10 years ago like a
lazy podcast like we're gonna play games
on that like you know lazy you don't do
anything for it you just show up we do
all the work oh my god yeah right
how am i wrong
with what i always contribute you never
have like first of all when you were
doing all the podcasts it was like
keemstar jake paul and everyone's like
we're so sick of hearing about this
because it's everything i saw in this
you had stuff from last h3 you just
recycle h3 content on frenemies you're
like oh we're gonna do trisha through
the history meme or whatever you already
did that on the last episode and i said
i didn't bring it up i didn't say it but
the fact that it's already on there like
i had to bring up all these other topics
because i'm like i don't want to go to
that because you brought it up last week
let's see
we put together this gabby hannah
segment i mean i couldn't but i
literally again could have done that for
my head i always drive in with my topics
like i always do because like i try and
okay what did you bring on the logan
paul fight
i brought it up first of all because
you're like i don't even know what to
say about it yeah i don't even know why
people what i never pick the costumes i
never do the vlogs i give so many ideas
i say dancing for the vlogs i give all
these ideas and you don't it's just
what's wrong with that for you i don't
think it's a good segment
the people want to hear from us okay do
it
okay telling you my opinion and while
the vlogs we've done i've suggested
other vlogs and like that never does
well if you don't like it then we
shouldn't do it okay
there's a show about me and you no but
you're saying i do all the work but i'm
telling you i don't like all the stuff
you do i'm just gonna go with it because
i'm like okay i guess this is what you
want to do but i have to start saying no
because some things are just not good
ideas
hmm
i like it for the record
i hope some of you got really
interesting questions
they're not the home
hmm
brutal
brutal
i just don't like when we spend like
whatever
go ahead say there's a good question but
you're asking like
we do all the work it's like we spent
one frenemies rehashing all the stuff
you said about keemstar and h3 live
which was two days prior yeah it
happened one time no it's happened
before where you just like bring up
stuff that you've already mentioned like
and it's fine but are you attacking me
you asked me you said tell me and i'm
telling you like all your just because
you guys come up with everything doesn't
mean it's good it's recycled a lot of it
so it's like i can come up with a larva
a lot of it no um if you have ideas on
all yours i watch h3 live and we talk
about the same thing and i'm happy to
talk about it it's not always like that
it's happened before i agree it happened
last time i thought it happened a lot it
didn't happen last time did it
the title was like pregnancy
announcement which is i'm happy to talk
about the pregnancy we talked a lot
about the pregnancy but it wasn't the
pregnancy announcement history live was
it's your guys's thing which i'm happy
to talk about i'm happy for you guys but
to say like oh we don't recycle things
it's like you know you do and it's fine
but i don't make it the same title
because it's not an announcement we're
talking about i wouldn't say a recycling
it's a different conversation the
original one was trisha is going to like
something that doesn't have to be about
me but i'm just saying like the fact
that it's a pregnancy announcement again
when it's not a pregnancy announcement
because i'm not pregnant you know what i
mean we're talking about your guys's
pregnancy it was an announcement you
announced it on h3 live
oh you thought that it would people
would think it was about you
was because you already unless you're
just recycling the same title you did
for h3 live which is it's not this is
like i watch history live i don't want
to talk about it in front of me it's
like if we're being honest well we're
were gonna talk about ela being pregnant
of course yeah but the title has to be
pregnancy announcement
i don't see why that's a problem cause
you did that on friday you're just
recycling titles
it's not an announcement you weren't
announcing it okay so ela's pregnant and
i'm talking about it with trisha would
you prefer that anything to be more
creative it's like the fact that you
just talk about what you talked about
the week the week prior is like and i've
seen other people call it out it's not
just me like i mean people have called
it out before like the whole keemstars i
didn't even like didn't know it was like
the 30 minutes was exactly the 30
minutes you did on h3 live
hmm yeah i agree that part was that's
crazy sometimes i forget what i've
talked about but you're saying you have
all this crew that does all this work
for you and nobody could remember that
you talked about that two days prior
i agree somebody should have said
something
i got i was like guys why don't you tell
me when i'm talking about the same [ __ ]
over and over
because i tell to them i go yo make sure
to include this and they go oh okay but
i go oh [ __ ] i talked about the same
thing but i feel like you're so angry
about this literally not but it's so
funny i'm not i'm angry when you say you
need to admit when you're angry
ethan i promise you this is this is
really as gaslighting i go to a lot of
therapy right now and this really is
when i say i'm not angry i'm not i'm
like just trying to tell you that you're
like oh we do everything for the show
and i'm saying it's not always good i'm
not angry if i was angry i would like
leave or something but i'm not but you
tell me
or something you're not upset
okay all right but it is it is like
frustrating when you think you do all
this work and like think oh we're doing
all this great stuff and it's like
it's not that great sometimes a lot of
it is and i like appreciate all the work
you do and stuff like that but it's also
like not that great i don't get input on
like people we hire like all this stuff
like that i don't get i can hire why
would i ask you about people i hire
because it's front of me and you take
the budget for paying the crew that's
what you told me you take highlights you
take five percent to pay the crew so why
don't i get any input on the crew or
what we do these are employees of our of
our so why are you taking highlights and
five percent in front of me you told me
that that was to pay them that they
could be working or production costs
okay but you told me at the beginning
you told me at the beginning it's like
they could be working on other things so
i made that argument so i'm like well
they're already h3 oh they could be
working on other things so i'm like okay
in that case or production costs i take
five you i take five percent extra from
the podcast revenue
and i take the highlights revenue
and everything else we split
right so for production costs yeah
but again you were about to move us all
to downtown l.a and i was just like but
the production cost should be included
like we were going to share the cameras
because dan said oh we have to get new
computers and new cameras well i'm like
friends and i obliged you i said okay
fine but you fought it because we having
we bought a studio downtown that that
was always the plan by the way that we
were gonna move downtown and then all of
a sudden was like yo and i was like yo
we're moving i told you ahead of time
but it's fine because you didn't tell me
downtown still at my house now but i
said okay so i was like yo by the way we
moved into our new office we're going to
be there next week it's good and then
you're like oh i don't want to go down
there
and but we had made all these plans to
move the set and everything and to do
everything so you're like i don't want
to go down there and then we talked
about it for a little bit and i said
okay fine and so we had to buy but that
was the first time we ever spent money
on production costs it's not about that
dude it's literally about we are
producing the show and i'm taking a cut
i feel like that's beyond reasonable all
the highlights reasonable five percent
five percent do you realize how much
five percent was of our last one that
should be enough but also like
highlights and then you weren't the
membership i had to fight for because
you weren't like oh i forgot to tell you
about
of all the members even though we work
and do all the work i don't know why you
fight me on money the deal you have is
beyond reasonable okay no but i feel
like a lot of frustration you have about
everything with the frustrated when i'm
talking bringing stuff up you get
defensive i'm not frustrated i'm
pointing out these things because i
would like to know i just want
everything to be a lot more transparent
because i'm like what are the production
costs can't be more transparent can you
show me all the costs of production not
like a itemized thing we are doing the
show that's the cause you don't think
five percent is like enough of for the
five percent and the highlights was what
we agreed to beginning and that's what
it is oh my god okay if you think that's
what it's worth okay it's worth more
than that all right you're getting a
very generous deal and the sponsors that
we do we can that we work to get
right we do all the work to bring the
sponsors i mean i had all of that for
the first like
20 shows so i mean don't
i appreciate what you do but don't act
like i don't bring it i brought you adam
and eve and so that was one sponsor we
worked with that's all we had for the
first like and now we have tons of
sponsors every episode because it takes
time you know obviously to get the show
up and pitching and you get 50 of all of
that i feel like the deal you get is
super fair and i feel like you're
gaslighting me to be honest saying that
you're not like frustrated about it but
i'm not because it really is a source of
like every time something comes up where
it's like i hired somebody or this that
and like oh you don't do that much on
the show bringing attention to it i'm
not upset i would text you i would tell
you it comes down to
oh well you get this extra five percent
and so because you're saying why should
i get an input on the employees that's
what you said and you just brought it up
to me you don't just work on frenemies
they're my employees okay but when i
asked when i said that to you originally
you said oh we pay the employees they
could be working on other things so why
don't we have frenemies employees and i
get input if we're spending five percent
of the budget towards them
i think that's that's not what it is
that's what you said so then that that's
i don't remember it but then that
lighting is telling someone how they
feel and you're telling me how i feel
and i'm telling you i don't feel
frustrated or upset so i don't know what
what else that could be how am i
guessing you guys telling you i'm not
feeling this way how is that guess
lighting you i'm not feeling this way
okay i wouldn't show up i wouldn't come
here i would you know i you listen you
can be upset and not happy
because there's just you could be upset
and then also not be like
i'm not showing up [ __ ] you all like
there's levels if i was upset i'm just
explaining i'm just because you can be
upset and still show up i'm not upset
and that's what it is because you're
thinking i'm guys
saying you're not upset you're perfectly
the perfect condition right now okay wow
holy cow that's crazy
i mean i don't know how you i just don't
see what you just did that's that's
really what did i do
i need we i we have to end it now like
really
what did i do
we got to stop for real really
please please okay whenever you're ready
so no because i don't want to title this
it's the pizza curse can we just i'm not
going to title it
it's the pizza curse it is
we shouldn't have got pizza
pizza
the pizza oh no it's pizza trisha let me
just say i'm sorry ethan that you just
did that you're right you're right
nothing's wrong with you that's but i go
you don't know how much therapy i go to
a week i go to four zoom sessions a week
i understand
even what you just said was you're right
trisha everything's fine that's insane
like the fact that you did that to me is
like it's not insane we're friends we're
having a friendly conversation i don't
have to i shouldn't have to walk on
eggshells around everything i say all
right ethan we have them to end this i'm
asking you you can leave any time trisha
then you're making this thing where
we're not ending the show and you get to
sit here and be like okay well that just
happened and you're eating pizza and
then i will end the show the minute you
watch all right so let's just let's just
end it please thank you guys for
watching and i just i don't want it to
be a thing where you're just sitting
here eating pizza and you become a meme
so then i'll say i'm sorry
okay
obviously i don't want to get an
argument over here okay all right we're
done thank you guys thank you
you